SCP-682 Vs a Ton of Liquid Nitrogen.
After trying and failing to kill SCP-682 via
anomalous means, Dr. Carlson wished to return
to basics and try some non-anomalous murder
methods for bringing an end to this nasty
lizard.
The 682 tissue sample was successful.
It was frozen and shattered when struck with
a hammer, exactly as intended.
However, when 682-proper was doused with liquid
nitrogen, its body remained frozen and dormant…
For about ten minutes.
Then, it began increasing its body temperature
until it was thawed.
But it didn’t stop there.
It kept increasing its body temperature until
it was so hot that the walls of its containment
chamber began to melt.
Dr. Carlson noted, “Interesting, it retained
the adaption even after it was no longer necessary.
Maybe we should be more careful.”
SCP-682 Vs SCP-294.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile Vs The Coffee
Machine.
Could this supernatural Keurig brew up a final
victory over this ornery reptile?
Researchers got the machine to dispense “SCP-682
Killer”, and poured it onto a tissue sample.
The sample crumbled into a fine powder when
it made contact with the liquid, so they cumulatively
brewed up a liter of the stuff, and poured
it onto the actual SCP-682.
The affected areas decayed and crumbled just
like in the test, and when 682 was placed
back into its acid tank, the areas completely
dissolved.
The researchers felt incredibly hopeful, believing
that if a large enough quantity of SCP-682
Killer can be synthesized, it may actually
live up to its name.
We’ll let you know as soon as they try it
again with a venti order.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-923.
Can this terrifying, mind-melting satellite
finally drive SCP-682 off the edge?
Foundation researchers damaged 682 heavily
and took it out to an isolated field in Kansas
in order to find out.
SCP-923 fired down at 682 with its beam set
to Intensity level 75, known to have devastating
effects against the minds of its victims.
When the blast was unleashed, 682 began screaming
and howling obscenities at the sky and the
Foundation.
Then, its body began to adapt, growing glowing
nodes that fired out its own beams similar
to 923’s blasts, driving the observing Foundation
employees completely insane.
The test was considered such a failure that
one of the lead researchers on the SCP-682
termination project threatened to do something
REDACTED to whoever organized it.
SCP-682 Vs Extremely High Temperatures.
Could the monstrous Hard to Destroy Reptile
finally be roasted to death in a super-heated
room?
The researchers at the SCP Foundation hoped
so.
They locked it in a special chamber and increased
the temperature to truly immense proportions,
but rather than melting, as the researchers
had hoped, it developed a carapace of solid
helium, which defended it from the heat.
Even worse was that the carapace remained
in place, even as the room was reduced back
to safe temperatures.
When personnel were sent in to inspect the
creature, the carapace abruptly shattered
and exploded all over the room, shredding
everyone nearby.
682 had baited its victims inside, and gotten
a little payback for the extreme sauna session.
SCP-682 versus SCP-3922.
Who would win in this matchup between the
indestructible reptile and the TV reality
filter?
3922 is a small cylinder that, when placed
near a television, will alter the content
of any fictional material being played to
include a battalion of heavily armored soldiers
who proceed to arrest the characters in the
film and try them for their crimes.
The Foundation introduced 3922 to security
footage of 682.
The tape was then altered into a 72-hour military
epic in which a coalition of soldiers, all
played by deceased actors, attempted to terminate
682 over the course of the film.
The film ends with a final remaining soldier,
played by Patrick Swayze, alongside several
gigantic primates staring down 682 and preparing
to duke it out once and for all before…
a TO BE CONTINUED title card is displayed!
Talk about a sequel hook.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-117.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile Vs The Perfect
Multi-Tool.
But can this ultra-convenient and somewhat
vampiric gadget finally MacGuyver this nasty
lizard out of existence?
The Foundation started with a sample test,
using tissue extracted from 682’s back and
a D-Class in charge of holding the multitool.
The test looked promising.
117 produced a number of pneumatic hammers
and pounded the 682 tissue sample into a fine
slurry, then disintegrated this slurry into
nothingness with particle beam weaponry - leaving
the D-Class it was being handled by, with
an almost deadly mineral deficiency.
However, as you can probably guess, the test
against the whole 682 lizard wasn’t so successful.
Rather than attacking 682, 117 produced a
device that teleported itself and the D-Class
using it away, killing the D-Class in the
process.
Test failed.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-170.
Can the ultimate molecular superglue pin the
Hard to Destroy Reptile down for good?
The SCP-170 glue was laced onto a series of
metal chains, with the hope of confining rather
than executing the monster.
The tissue sample was promising, and things
proceeded from there.
682 was sedated and wrapped with chains which
were then connected to the ground.
Initially, when 682 woke up, it thrashed around
and tried to escape.
However, its attempts were futile.
But before the researchers could start patting
themselves on the back, 682 began to grow,
until it reached such a size that the chains
simply popped off.
The leading theory as to how this worked was
that it hadn’t technically grown, but increased
the distance between its particles, shattering
the molecular bond created by SCP-170.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-049.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile is certainly a
pretty pestilent creature, but would the mild-mannered
Plague Doctor be able to cure our world of
its presence?
SCP-049 slowly approached the creature, seeming
equal parts fascinated and frightened.
It murmured, “The disease appears to not
affect only humans…” to itself.
It closed in to get a better look and tried
to grab 682, but the reptile immediately growled
and swiped at 049.
The doctor narrowly dodged taking any real
damage, but the experience shook him.
He seemed panicked and a little emotionally
disturbed.
At his own request, he was escorted back to
his containment chamber.
Poor guy.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-2855.
They say that money makes the world go round,
but can Mr. Money put the reptile underground?
SCP-2855, or Mr. Money, is part of Dr. Wondertainment’s
Little Misters series.
His ability is having whatever capabilities
his buyer believes he has, so he was sold
to a member of the O5 Council as “A man
who can permanently destroy SCP-682, and will
do so immediately upon completion of this
transaction.”
However, this didn’t happen.
Instead, he disappeared for an hour, during
which time SCP-682 seemed to show no ill effects.
He later reappeared next to the Council Member,
dazed and experiencing memory loss, with a
note that read:
“Oops!
Dr. Wondertainment offers the sincerest of
apologies for the unanticipated malfunction
of your Mr. MoneyTM.
We will be working to correct this error in
future products.”
SCP-682 Vs SCP-093.
Our dimension can’t seem to keep the Hard
to Destroy Reptile down, but maybe the dimension
that SCP-093, the Red Sea Object, offers us
access to across the mirror plane might have
better luck?
The object passed around SCP-682 until it
turned green and affixed itself to a nearby
mirror, purposefully selected to be big enough
to allow SCP-682 through.
When it refused to enter, the mirror was brought
over, 682 was pushed in, and then the mirror
was shattered.
However, later on, the mirror anomalously
put itself back together and SCP-682 was pushed
back out - Because of course he was.
SCP-682 commented, of his time on the other
side:
“'I am not very amused.”
SCP-682 VS SCP-5871.
Could the knife that retroactively erases
its victims from the timeline finally remove
the Hard to Destroy Reptile from our past,
present, and future?
SCP-682 was bound in place by restraints to
prevent it from escaping and a researcher
using SCP-5871 slashed it, erasing it from
existence.
From that point on, a CK-Class Reality Restructuring
Event occurred, and post-restructure researchers
were unable to find any traces of SCP-682.
It seemed almost like it never existed.
However, soon after this, the effects were
reversed by SCP-682’s adapting abilities.
682 returned to reality, then the test we
just described was erased from existence - as
well as SCP-5871.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-101.
Could the Hungry Bag finally be the anomaly
that doesn’t find the Hard to Destroy Reptile
too tough to swallow?
SCP-101, the Hungry Bag, is a small, tooth-lined
bag seemingly connected to a limitless pocket
dimension, capable of devouring almost anything.
Dr. Lee Roy Carlson suggested it might be
perfect to finish off 682 after it was reduced
in size by another anomaly.
So after SCP-682 was shrunk down by a confrontation
with SCP-165-1, its tiny body was thrown into
the gaping maw of SCP-101, and swallowed up.
Later, however, SCP-101 began to gurgle for
an extended period.
After a prolonged period of discomfort, it
belched up the tiny SCP-682, which later returned
to its normal size.
SCP-682 VS SCP-3042.
Could the ultimate case of Puppy Love be the
force to counteract SCP-682’s reptilian
hatred?
Let’s take a look and see.
SCP-3042 is a small but superpowered dog that
bonds with one individual at a time, and basically
gradually loves them to death with constant
and unyielding affection.
Its latest favorite person was eaten by SCP-682,
causing SCP-3042 to imprint on the monster
as a replacement.
However, this was disastrous, as SCP-682 immediately
attacked the tiny dog, causing it to run away
in fear.
SCP-3042 charged through a nearby wall - thankfully
making a hole too small for SCP-682 to escape
through - and imprinted on a nearby guard.
Another test failed.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-407.
Could the Song of Genesis alter the Hard to
Destroy Reptile out of existence, finally
making it true music to the SCP Foundation’s
ears?
At 25 seconds, 682 did not seem at all soothed
by the music.
At 45 seconds, the creature’s wounds from
a previous test healed rapidly, and it made
a high-pitched noise.
At 1:25, 682 screamed, and its mouth began
to fill with a white, foamy substance.
At 1:55, it swallowed this same substance
and started choking.
However, at 2:35, it squired all the substance
out of its mouth in a powerful jet.
And at 3:55, 682 remained unconscious for
five minutes to heal, and then awoke, utterly
unaffected by the Song of Genesis.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-165.
Could the Hard to Destroy Reptile finally
be devoured by the combined forces of the
creeping, hungry sands of tule?
A large SCP-165 sample was placed beneath
a trapdoor, with 682 positioned above it.
When the monster was dropped into the hill
of teeming, flesh-eating mites, they began
devouring it.
It was engulfed in the dune and remained in
there for ten minutes before the dune ceased
activity, and a much smaller version of SCP-682
crawled out.
The Fire Eaters were called in to blast both
and return 682 to its containment chamber.
In all likelihood, 682 had emitted a pesticide
that killed off the mites, while a smaller
version of itself hid inside its own skull
until it was safe to emerge and attempt escape.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-067.
While this particular cross test was never
expected to destroy or even harm the Hard
to Destroy Reptile, researchers figured that
this all-telling Fountain pen might glean
valuable information about the monster.
SCP-067 is a pen that causes people to compulsively
write or draw about themselves.
When the pen was given to SCP-682, it was
horribly surprised when it began drawing a
complex image on the floor.
When the image was done, it threw the pen
across the room.
The resulting picture was a self-portrait
of SCP-682, sitting atop a legion of dead
Roman soldiers, marked as the Ninth Legion
- which had historically, mysteriously disappeared.
They may have been no closer to defeating
SCP-682, but at least they solved that mystery.
scp 682 versus scp-1437 could dropping 682
in a hole to another place finally get rid
of it for good to begin the test 682 was thrown
into 1437 at 1 hour 3 minutes 23 seconds scp-682
was expelled from 1437 in the shape of a large
glass object filled with a red blood-like
liquid an on-site bulldozer pushed it back
down the hole at 13 hours 12 minutes 7 seconds
scp-682 was expelled from the hole again in
the form of a round mechanical device that
released a dangerous gas and had a mouth full
of gold teeth the bulldozer pushed it back
down at 27 hours 20 minutes scp-682 was propelled
out of 1437 it had returned to its original
shape with the exception of a larger body
shorter snout and a variety of weapons embedded
in its body
SCP-682 Vs SCP-938.
Can this electrical entity provide an adequate
shock to 682’s system?
SCP-682 was placed in a containment chamber
attached to Site-07.
An electric device was brought into the room
and routed into SCP-938.
The device increased in electrical voltage
to the point that it damaged SCP-682, causing
burns to its body and paralyzing it for one
hour.
At this point, it regained motion capabilities
and shot electricity from its spine through
its head.
Then, it lost consciousness - though it was
still breathing - and remained that way for
several days as its body recovered.
Not quite as electrifying as the Foundation
had hoped, so it appeared.
The researcher for this test, Dr. Carly, did
at least note that electrical or mind-based
SCPs did tend to keep SCP-682 immobilized
longer than physical or chemical attacks.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-858.
Could Gravity’s Rainbow finally clear the
dark cloud of the unkillable reptile, and
bring sunny skies to the SCP Foundation?
A tissue sample from 682, repelled from Earth’s
gravity at a speed of 9.8 m/s was destroyed
by SCP-858.
When SCP-682 was exposed to 858, it began
to fall away from the Earth’s surface at
the same rate as the sample.
It reached 858, but it did not disappear.
It hit some sort of invisible barrier, and
its body appeared to be slowly boiling.
This continued until the reptile had lost
50% of its body mass.
When half of its body was gone, 682 suddenly
sprouted a pair of wings similar to those
of pterosaurs, in addition to an array of
air bladders that allowed it to fly perpendicular
to SCP-858’s gravity.
SCP-682 Vs SCP-539.
Could the Perfect Distraction take 682’s
attention away from the one thing it cares
about: hatred?
A member of D-class personnel was sent into
SCP-682’s containment chamber, carrying
SCP-539.
Then, the doors were shut behind them.
Terrified that SCP-682 would kill them, the
D-Class threw SCP-539 early in an attempt
to distract it.
As soon as SCP-539 was thrown, the site experienced
a system malfunction in the containment chamber.
An acid pump was activated during this malfunction,
trapping SCP-682 for approximately 20 minutes
before it was deactivated by site maintenance
staff.
By the time staff reached the containment
chamber, 85% of 682’s body had been destroyed.
SCP-539 was found nearby, and the D-class
was completely gone.
Three hours later, SCP-682 was completely
recovered, plus an additional pair of legs
grown during the healing process.